little boozy is that his name yeah he's
a rapper who basically sounds like a
cartoon character
so he was on theo von show and they were
talking about what needs to be done with
the black community
and of course boozy's black for those
that are well you'll know very soon
do you feel like one of the biggest
things that plagues the black community
is just not having to find the finances
i don't know man i think i think we need
to build our own economy that's why i
think we can we got to move right now
with the rise and [ __ ] we can build our
own economy we need to get the
billionaires together you should own
more your [ __ ]
we should build our own economy make our
own music yeah we should bail out to our
own banks yep you know uh good luck
there
guys um
good luck there should somebody somebody
tell them that they already that they
had that
they had their own
stuff
they never they never had their own
banks
certain groups like to
same thing what they did with black wall
street back in the days in tulsa
oklahoma yeah i know that they they
what happened they burned it down yeah
they burned who say they down took
everything you know we black those black
people all those black people worth
millions of dollars that will be
billions today right so uh we probably
need to start our own economy man
economy
yeah so that's when you fold paper into
like swans
it's like
stupid economy is a is a gaming company
they used to make a lot of the old
fighting games oh the economy code like
up up down down left right left right ba
starting yeah yeah yeah yeah okay you're
right you're right hey man sorry i'm
just trying to school you man i
appreciate it
i appreciate it
no no no i'm sorry economy is a uh i'm
sorry i i was wrong too it's a japanese
soup mmm
it's delicious it's a little beans in it
that sounds good
economy off our own foods our own why
don't you start with a napkin to dig the
spittle off the [ __ ] side of your
mouth
he always is smoking weed everywhere and
he always has a dry mouth like with
white crust not like he's he's always
like this he's he's
probably one of the worst shitty rappers
and he's a [ __ ] like i i don't i'm not
a fan of boosie i even in my hood rat
days i never liked boosie uh and
everybody get together make it make our
own economic yeah you know what i'm
saying economy and i like how theo's
just going yeah
totally bro economy
theo looks like every scared white guy
that gets like
cornered by a black guy who's not doing
anything
but
it's just cornering them and babbling
and you don't want to say anything
because you don't want to get beat out
you're like yeah uh-huh i feel you bro
even if we got it even if we got to get
fronted from
somebody else yeah but we can start
we can start our own economy out what if
you did i can't i can't the way he says
that is bothering me so much think about
and just hear me out on this uh mr
badass or disease
um
if you wanted to start your own economy
stop hitting me out on this please don't
what if you were to
just and i'm not this isn't directed at
your entire community this is directed
specifically as you as a person tabooji
boozy
boozy badass
previously known as lil boozy now he's
normal sized boozy um
well because he leveled up like a
pokemon like a pokemon oh okay
what if you were to let's say if you
wanted to start your own economy
and you wanted these people you wanted
to support your own community what if
you
spent
less money on marijuana and jewelry and
lean
and titty bars and cars that you lease
you don't even buy them
what if you were to take all that money
and invest that into your economy and
then you could
get your community to rise up so the
problem is
is that you're incapable of doing that
again i want to clarify
that i am only speaking to this one
individual i am not making a stereotype
or any kind of generalization i know
your chain but you seem to be
physically incapable
or inherently incapable of
um managing money holding on to money um
investing money is he missing a finger
maybe i don't know
but but maybe you need to work on
instead of worrying about what you're
owed
and reinvest in your own economy and
build it up instead of
wasting your money on frivolous things
like alcohol and lap dances and stupid
[ __ ] quarter of a million dollar cars
that you lease just a thought just a
thought that maybe
um
if you did that you'd have businesses
you see there's a reason why
asians and arabs are destroying
everybody
uh including white people in in the
category of building businesses up it's
because
asians and arabs
really extract
absolutely no joy from money
remember i'm
right you don't i would agree with some
of that like you don't see a lot of some
arabs do whatever but you know they'll
get like one but they'll get like one
nice ring and they'll have one nice car
and that's it but like
arabs koreans there's certain groups of
people that just don't
they don't flash money they don't get
joy out of blowing money
they just kind of go well i i need this
money to build my business up um but a
lot of them are just meh whatever um
james price's arabs what about walid bin
talal well that's when you're talking
about these like saudi guys that just
have like they they have what you would
basically have like when you remember
when you play sim city and you could
just enter in cheats and you just said
unlimited money they have cheat codes so
they can spend money like that i know
like well
going what you're saying indians in
america at least i can't i'm just
because
they know that i i know quite a few
who are
loaded i mean when i say loaded i mean
they [ __ ]
multi-millionaires don't show it don't
get me wrong they have a nice car but
it's just you know a nice but a
reasonable mercedes their their house
isn't nice it's in a nice neighborhood
gated commuter but it's a nice hot
they're not flossing you know whatever
indians will be
liquid in the bag six million and
they'll still shop at target anymore
that's just how they are you could tell
because that's how they dress because
they're like i don't i just need a
powder pants i don't care what kind of
pants like they just you know what i
mean there's none of this like yeah yo i
got that new yo i got the new ferragamo
yo i got this new versace like indians
aren't like oh i like the ferragamo
sauce
they're just like they go to target and
they go uh only
they'll an indian millionaire will go
into a target and they'll go sir
uh those pants right there uh buy two
get one four buy two two get one half
off i i only need two pair of pants i
don't need the third power punch
the third one is half off i only need
two pair of pants like oh
okay he doesn't want the third pair for
half off he just he's very adamant about
only needing two pairs of pants like
it's maybe boosie you should get with
your boys and tell them to cut the [ __ ]
our own state you know and oh hey
you're preaching to the choir brother
is he calling for an ethno state like
some sort yo it's like if we had our own
economy in like our own state where
let's say we just only had our own kind
you know i mean like you know i'm saying
had our own communities
and we just and then the whites would
have their own communities you're like
based busy
you know what i was saying it's like you
know we like we must secure
a future if we don't like start securing
them for the little [ __ ] for
the little
little kids we must secure an existence
and a future for our kids
yo that's why my new albums call the 14
words
they do love the math analogies in their
albums
and let's see how much they miss us and
we can and we can put a real hole in
their pocket yeah cause we run the
fashion we run all this [ __ ] up
you know
no you don't run the fashion the gays
run the fashion yeah you wear the
fashion i'll say that gays design it
and french people put their name on it
and
another certain group of people own
everything and and and sweat sweatshops
in china make it so
that's how it goes
you know the black people run the
fashion a lot of us
even white people want to look like us
okay
okay thank you so then why am i getting
in trouble for blackface yeah exactly
come on
like imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery exactly and i like to put big
old [ __ ] red lips and go mammy
so come on
no but i also love the way this is this
argument that black people always make
we're at the forefront of fashion people
are always trying to look like us but
you're not designing producing or
distributing this [ __ ] you're not making
money off of it you're buying it your
purchasers your consumers
so just because you're trendsetting
consumers that doesn't translate into
you being great business people am i
wrong here like diddy has entered the
chat you don't you're not
you're buying the [ __ ] and then people
go damn that dude looks cool in that
shirt i think fly is what you're looking
for but you're not making this [ __ ]
no real [ __ ] especially if they're 14 or
15. come on 14 15 years old you know
they didn't
oh you wanted to be ice cube i remember
writing ice cube on my cheek before i go
to school bro
i'm [ __ ]
i'm cringing
i'm cringing so bad
oh theo the ice cube thing's not what
made me cringe do you want to know what
made me cringe oh theo do you know what
made me cringe what the theo von said
bruh
theo vaughn was that brad there's
nothing funnier than like a white boy
from louisiana with a mullet trying to
relate to a black guy you know what i
mean oh hell yeah man i used to ride ice
cube on my thing bro like you have no
idea
did you write it on your transport
backpack man it's like you know i i'm
always trying to relate to him you know
i mean like i i'll beat up my pregnant
girlfriend and then i handle money
poorly
that's how much i wanted to be and i
wanted to be like every every when you
see that that fashion with that rap [ __ ]
yeah it attracts you man even if you
don't know the music yeah you want the
jacket you want the michael jackson
hat you want you know yeah so
we can make it it's just it's the
ownership it was the ownership that's
what it is yeah so i was saying i was
thinking i thought i was talking about
this with my pro scrim guy who uh who
who i do pro scrimmage what's pro scrim
i'm translating i i
wow you don't know i had a loss what's
pro scrim
i'm not a lost can somebody in the chat
can can one of our
can the black listener in the chat
please let us know what pro scrim is
i'm a
pro scrim
ps4 shrimp
professional shrimp professional
shrimping company
somebody said skyrim
i don't i don't i don't know i don't i
don't know
black rugby they called it no it's i
don't think that's what it is it's like
you know sometimes like i man i love
y'all guys so much man like sometimes i
just carry like an illegal gun on me you
know what i mean and like i just be
knocking up girls and i never speak to
him again or anything
my credit score is like 300 dude that's
how much i like you guys
[Laughter]
it's a gaming company you know
pro scrim is a gaming company
i i really don't think you're going to
find anything with pro scrim he can't
speak so no but i need to understand no
mike i'm sorry but i need to understand
pro-scrim is a gaming company
pro scrim is a gaming company
a lot of people are saying fortnite in
the chat maybe that's
it is a gaming company that's all i know
of pro scrim
pro scrim so okay says guy guess i i
don't i don't know
maybe i'm out of touch
first we will have to buy the land
that's what we have to do first how do
you do that we would have to buy the
land you know they got they got a lot of
cheap land out there we have to buy land
man we have people doing it tyler perry
has that huge place in atlanta he has
that huge studio hey busy you're wearing
potential land right now around your
neck
you're right
you could buy
literally right now what he's wearing
around his neck he could buy three or
four lots in baltimore
where they actually like uh
already demolish the the row houses he
could buy like four spots with the row
houses used to be just with what's on
his neck
you you don't
you don't want to
like seriously
this is the argument that people always
have and then they'll call you a racist
right america is a place where
you can actually be
whatever you desire
i mean just you might not get a hundred
percent of where you want to go
but like
america is a place where
even if you grew up in a house full of
crackheads being abused you know
whatever the [ __ ]
you can
you can work towards a thing
and you can get there there's nothing
stopping like is there anything in
america that's stopping most people from
being what they want to be if they will
put in the work to be what the [ __ ] they
want to be
especially i remove this from i
understand a guy like him with his iq is
probably not going to be a district
attorney for new york city i get that
for chicago maybe
buying land royce
is this a country that makes it
difficult for a guy in his position who
makes as much money as him to buy land
no is that hard theo brought up a really
good point to tyler perry did it
he bought land he bought you know
it's
then dave chappelle yeah dave chappelle
owns a [ __ ] half a day in ohio now
you know what i mean it's it's because
dave chappelle was like yeah i like to
waste money on cigarettes and weed and
[ __ ] like that and get a little [ __ ]
here and there but like
i still put most of my money back into
how do i build this thing
yeah but that's for movies right but i'm
talking about for life right i'm talking
about sending out
kids to school
sending out kids making making them
business minded right so you
okay i'm just i'm again i'm only going
by what he's saying here
you want
your own businesses
and your own schools which by the way
you already have
you already have your own no no i get it
but that but that's what you want
all right
i was kind of racist people are calling
him a fool in the chat
as i said at the beginning of this i've
never been a boosie fan
he is an absolute
[ __ ] and i mean that
even even grading him on a curve because
he's a rapper he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh even for a rapper he's even for
a rapper he's stupid because i would
agree with that there are some rappers
who are low-key geniuses
believe it or not
two chains
is a goddamn
genius he really is two chains his
music's [ __ ] and i've heard him an
interview say yeah i'm marketing to
[ __ ] people
which is why i have to make my music
this way it's about making a catchy
[ __ ] thing and selling records but
two chains
absolutely knocked nancy grace the [ __ ]
out on her own show
two chains has been in interviews
absolutely smart guy um
there are plenty of rappers that i've
seen interviews where you're like damn
this guy really knows [ __ ] you know what
i mean somebody else said lupe fiasco
there's another one yeah this is like
well those are the ones you'd expect but
i'm talking about ones you'd expect like
guys that make the same music he does
gotcha and two chainz is one of those
guys where you go
jesus christ i just talked to two chains
for 20 minutes the guy's a [ __ ]
genius guy's smart you know he's like he
he's going to be one of those guys that
leaves his kids [ __ ] he's going to have
[ __ ] money when he dies um he's this
is just [ __ ] he's this guy's an absolute
like 40 iq idiot
well isn't like rizza like an
astrophysicist and [ __ ] like
he is i believe he is even if he's not
doesn't have a degree in that rizza has
gone on to score movies and act and
write things
rises beyond just some like
yeah man y'all we need to build our own
economy like you never hear wristbands
saying that
and by the way don't sleep on the bobby
digital album that's one of the greatest
albums ever and nobody nobody gives that
album any love
yeah apparently guru from gangstar
is another i'm just seeing ones that
like you wouldn't think
isn't guru dead
i don't know he was sick
he's dead
pretty sure he's gangstar is like one of
my favorite
were one of your favorite
be rich not just for film i'm talking
about a life a whole state of life
black life livelihood yeah our own
[ __ ] tomato everything yeah and we
will hurt the world man we would hurt
the world
we were hurting so you don't
want to make your life better you want
to hurt the world
it's it's just it's weird right it's
just babbling
it's it's this is the kind of
boozy
talks like people doing their own a
bunch of coke
and they're all over the place
and they're just manic
so you don't want to make things better
you just want to hurt people the world
and we and once we do that we probably
can start our own laws because they got
[ __ ] towns they got hit towns
in these states that own their own land
that their police station had their own
laws yeah
um
there are plenty of places where the
police won't go where you guys have your
own laws and we're being fair right i
mean
yeah you're right the hit this hit like
this guy this i'm already picking it up
from him this guy just [ __ ] doesn't
like white people like he's one of those
right he just doesn't like white people
all white people are bad he's hit towns
they got their own law
and we would have we buy the [ __ ]
land and we have our own law
it's just black people don't don't
don't
don't want to put it together like that
that's how i feel what have you done
where's your land
what school have you opened
seriously what school have you opened
who are you helping
because all this talk it's like but he
doesn't do anything